well this is my chair this is where i
sit
in my study here
i'm going to show you what it looks like
as we here we have all my books in
different languages
and as i go and i will show you
the view that i have here
and i don't know how well i'm going to
do this
but you can see
as outside
i look out onto this little yacht harbor
and i come back here
and there i have my little workstation
and now i'm going to go back
here
to my chair
where i sit and think about language and
i will continue from there
now you'll notice i'll have to adjust
this a little bit
you'll notice that uh how does that look
because the tv is the computer is far
away
but you know i'm in my grubbies
um i finished dinner i've even done the
dishes
which is my job
and i'm sitting here in my short pants
and t-shirt
and i just finished loading up
a comment
for uh
for my blog
and uh i'm just kind of curious about
all this technology and and how we can
make
um
these uh
you know videocast so easily so this is
a trial i'm sitting far away from my
computer i'm not quite sure how it's all
going to work out it's test number one
and we'll see what happens